As a job for the past 10 years
and also asrecreation, just for fun,
I create languages.
You know why languages
die on our planet?
It'snot because government imposes
one language on a smaller group,
or because an entire group
of speakers is wiped out.
That certainly has happened in the
past, and it's happening now,
butit's not the main reason.
The main reason is that
a child is born to a family
that speaks a languagethat is not
widely spoken in their community,
and that child doesn't learn it.
Why?
Because thatlanguage is not
valued in their community.
Maybe if more people are
studying more languages,
itwill lead to more linguistic tolerance
and less linguistic imperialism.
Maybe if we actuallyrespect
language for what it is --
literally, the greatest invention
in the historyof humankind --
then in the future,
we can celebrate endangered
languages asliving languages,
as opposed to museum pieces.